hi i'm tony the game director and
co-founder here at player first games
we're here today to give you a first
look at our new game multiverses
about two years ago we had a question
can we create a platform fighter that
embodies everything we love about the
genre removes the pain points and brings
in some new ideas
multiverses emphasizes teamwork and
social play with an ever expanding
diverse cast of characters that you know
and love
this is our take on the competitive
platform fighter
cooperative deep combat mechanics across
multiple platforms and free to play
everything is better with your friends
and that's a bond we want to emphasize
across our modes especially in 2v2
every character has unique moves that
focus on team play whether that's a
smoke bomb or batman to cover your
team's movement batman out steven
shielding his ally for extra defense you
need a shield saving someone with a
lasso tree
or using bugs bunny's tunnel
the better your teamwork the better your
chances are to win you're under my
production we built the game from the
ground up for teamwork and co-op to
deliver a more unique experience we
think players will enjoy and for those
of us who like to play solo don't worry
we support that too
a wolf of house stark is not afraid
our roster has some of the most
recognizable characters so bring them to
life with as close to one-to-one
representation as possible through
visuals their worlds
their music and more is important to us
that's why iconic voice talent powers
many of our characters like kevin conroy
as batman i am batman in fact we think
you'll recognize a lot of them bet you
didn't know about my dancing powers my
roommate thinks i have anger issues
let's see what you think get ready to
eat my sword we're excited to show you
our takes on characters from tom and
jerry it's arya
each fighter in multiverses is unique
and we'll have a range of customizations
available for all of them and that's
just the tip of the iceberg i'm gonna
eat so many scooby sniffs
multiverses supports cross play and
cross progression so you can focus on
what's important who you'll play with on
what platform you want friendship power
that also means guilds and more social
futures
get ready to challenge other guilds with
yours and to who's really ready for a
fight we'll have leaderboards and other
ways to prove who's the best
remember the last time you deceived from
a match what about lag affecting your
inputs us two multiverses goal is best
in class online we're investing a lot
into making the most responsive gameplay
in netcode in addition to dedicated
servers from day one for the life of the
game
our vision for multiverses is that
anyone and anything is possible we'll
serve our community with regular updates
including new characters modes skins
and events throughout the year for you
and your friends with your help we want
to grow multiverses to the best game it
can be so whether you want to freeze all
your foes at once or compete in esports
you'll have a home here batman vs
superman let's settle this once and for
all that's our first look into
multiverses we've got more iconic
characters and features to reveal sign
up at multiverses.com for a chance to
participate in our upcoming playtests we
want to hear your feedback
victory i haven't even broken a sweat
you